Hello Freak bitches,
that fucking story that you're telling
on stage now,
the story that you told about the
prostitute situation when you encouraged
me to do it.
So funny crying.
I'll,
I'll tell.
I'll tell a,
your our listeners now,
they're our listeners because everybody,
the Joe and Ron show.
Thank you.
I'll be here every Thursday at 1:30.
But it was true.
It's a lot of lost my virginity when I
was 18 years old to a girl,
a prostitute and a in Tijuana,
Mexico who was overweight and her teeth
had no general direction or color,
but she was well within my budget
but I got stationed at Pearl and if I
found that after a while when she'd been
on a one part of Awahoo wasn't hotel st
these really cute girls jumping your car
and blow you for $5.
And it was like the best deal I've ever
even heard of.
I mean,
I was like,
they're twice a day,
you know.
And uh,
I was there for eight months and then
six months ago I was watching this
documentary on transvestites and they
started talking about the transvestite
scene on hotel street on a wall who had
been there for 55 years.
I'm like,
no,
I let a hundred 50 dudes suck my dick.
What's the record?
What's the record before you find out?
Right when I went to record is that,
I don't know,
but God,
I have to be close.
You know,
I've dodged that bullet,
but I've come close a gang of time.
I think I've dodged a bullet.
Yeah.
If,
if I had to dodge the bullet,
Kudos.
Whenever thing pretended to be her,
apparently it tongue is a tongue and the
tooth is the tooth because you can't
tell man,
man from woman mouth.
Now,
if it would have been a hand job,
I'd been going,
hey,
you're a plumber dude.
That hand on my cock thick gorilla head.
Jesus,
what do you think I am?
Yeah.
And I would imagine that somebody who
has a Dick probably knows how to work
it.
I guess I'll tell you what,
these girls had made quick work at me
twice a day.
Forty five seconds.
I was in my little dots and headed back
to the ship.
Do you say girls with air quotes?
With air quotes girls?
Yeah.
Well I still don't like to think of them
as dude,
you know,
in my mind that I don't let myself go
there.
They're still hot little girls,
not little girls.
These were fully developed men with
Ted's Dad tits.
They did.
And I was always wondering what,
let me play with her pose,
you know,
they let you get some teddy,
but you started going down there where
the junk is and they were like swat and
your hand away and I'm like,
now that should have been,
you know,
my flag.
I don't know.
Yeah,
well now you know.
Yeah.
Right.
So what were you were in the navy?
Is that what you're doing?
How long?
I wasn't in real long.
Uh,
they uh,
you know,
I just wasn't cut out for it.
Uh,
that had,
that I had the wrong mouth for that.
Stayed in trouble.
I didn't,
you know,
it just did a lot of drugs and you know,
I just,
it was horrible out and then they
discharged me with an honorable
discharge under medical conditions from
the Naval Drug Rehabilitation Center in
Miramar,
California.
Oh Wow.
So what did,
what did you have to get rehabilitated
for?
Well,
I'd actually never seen drugs till I got
to the Naval Drug Rehabilitation Center
in Miramar,
California.
I mean everybody had drugs,
you know,
I was positive for heroin on a WESTPAC,
but,
so we're eight other people on the ship
and,
and uh,
then when we ate a ton of acid and you
know,
it was 75 and that was 18 years old and
that was off the hook.
Wild.
And uh,
and you know,
they just started actually in my,
in my hearing to get me out the,
the,
the commander of our base called me a
hole in our national land of defense.
I'm like,
God,
that's horrible.
But what's worse than that?
I wonder
nothing like when you see their bodies,
you see a bear's body and you think of a
500 pound bear.
What's this thing would have 500 pound
dog could do to you?
Right?
Just think of that,
right?
A 500 pound dog.
Then.
Have you ever seen like a baby bear
wrestle a dog.
It's fucking hilarious.
Day.
It's like Habib Neuroma,
Gamete of wrestling.
Your grandmother.
This is bare.
Just throws this fucking dog around
legged a shit.
It's a little cub as a little baby bear.
Look,
look at this.
Gosh,
look,
the dog keeps fucking with them.
The bears way smaller than the bears.
Like.
All right bitch.
You want to get crazy?
All right,
let's get crazy.
So they start going to war and the bear,
the bear whips him to the ground.
They put the dog keeps fucking with the.
Look at this.
Boom.
Look around.
Wow,
dude.
He just throws him around.
He's way smaller than that dog.
The dog is like,
oh no.
What have I done?
Look at this.
Boom,
bitch.
Boom.
Side control.
Like the bear can do shit that dog can't
do.
The doc had only bite,
but that bear has ridiculous power in
those arms.
Show that last 15 seconds.
Again,
look,
he throws him.
He uses his hips like,
look,
go back a little bit.
This bear is like a fucking judo champ.
Like,
watch.
This is like some Cairo,
Parisians Shit.
Look,
boom.
He just throws them around.
Boom,
seriously.
Stocky risks around that.
Bail is.
That's like Daniel Cormier that bear.
He uses his hips,
man,
like instinctively uses his hips.
Now imagine one of those,
it's 500 pounds and wants to eat.
You.
Imagine what the fucking sheer terror of
that would be.